- So here, are you feeling anything now?
- Yeah, it's crazy, when I
look out into the audience
all I see in here is dead people.
I feel like I'm connecting.
- Oh my God, it's the
the movie "Sixth Sense"
you're that boy.
- It is, I feel like I'm
connecting with the funeral home
because all of these souls that are here,
you know trying to speak
and trying to connect
and first of all your mom's departum?
Your mom's sitting right next to you,
can I get up?
- What, what?
- Your mother's right here.
The way that it works for me
is that when I'm in a room
or I'm in an area, all
of your souls are trying
to come through and speak
and she was just sitting
next to you and saying,
"That's my daughter,
"that's my daughter."
So know it's your mom's
way of just acknowledging
that you're here and letting
you know that she is okay.
This was a woman who had
suffered before her passing
here in the physical world.
- Yes.
- 'Cause what happens is Kelly,
is that they'll put me back
in their body to show me what had gone on,
and they'll stand next to
you to show you they're here
and she showed me she couldn't breathe
before she had passed.
- Yes, she was put on a ventilator.
- I feel like I'm drowning,
but I'm connected to her.
- What?
- Yeah, she had a heart attack,
I was in the emergency room,
she was 62 years old.
- [Kelly] That's young.
- Your mom says to me,
that first of all she want's
to thank you for keeping
a promise to her, she
says you promised to her
that you weren't gonna leave
her side 'cause she was afraid,
she says, "And do you
know that my daughter
"stayed with me all night long."
And you laid on the side
of her and laid with her
and your mom just wants
to say, thank you so much
for allowing my soul to go the other side.
- Yeah.
- Can I give you a hug?
(audience clapping)
- She also says, when
I'm connecting with her
that you feel her all the
time, 'cause she shows
me that she's in the house with you
and you talk with her
and you mom says, "I hear
everything that you do."
She says, "So, thank
you for laying with me,
"staying with me and making
"my journey to the other side okay."
She says, "'Cause I couldn't
have done it without you."
She say, "And thank you
for respecting my wishes."
Right, give her a round of applause.
- Wow.
(audience applause)
So wait I have a question.
- Yes.
- I mean, so wait you can come over here,
'cause I want to ask you this,
because you just brought up
the journey afterwards, right?
So do a lot of people ask
you, sorry I'll wait for you
to sit down, but wait, oh I'm so sorry.
- Oh that's okay.
- Do a lot of people ask you
what happens after people
pass, after they die?
Or I will, what happens?
(laughs)
I don't know if others do
but do you, I mean 'cause
if you see them, what do you
think happens when we die?
- So what happens is is
that when you first pass on,
'cause I read for a lot of
people and their loved ones
will come through and tell
me what happens afterwards
and when you first pass
on and when you first go
the other side, you're
immediately greeted by family
members that had passed,
family members, pets,
people that had passed
on, they're all there,
it's literally like one big family reunion
on the other side.
- Okay, well thank you for
doing, that was incredible
and I am
mind blown.
(audience clapping)
That you even knew all those details
is so creepy and awesome,
I am so glad I don't
see dead people though
so please dead people
if you're in the room,
I can't handle it,
just so you know.